a big change in downtown las vegas
overnight
the greyhound bus terminal next to the
plaza hotel shut down
going to be a new project there our
bialco holmen is live with the details
what's it all about bianca
hey good morning nate so the bus
terminal has been here for about 50
years
but the plaza hotel and casino did not
renew its lease
so the buses they'll have to park
somewhere else now here's some more
information about the changes coming to
downtown las vegas plaza ceo jonathan
jossel announced
the move in a tweet calling it the end
of an error
the plaza plans to redevelop the old bus
terminal building it will include
shops restaurants and entertainment the
plaza is also partnering with the city
of las vegas to build a pedestrian
bridge over the train tracks
to connect the hotel to symphony park
and a new
800 unit apartment complex jostle
announced back in december the hotel
wouldn't renew the lease for the bus
station
it also provides us with about two acres
of space
whereby we can redevelop it into
something that's going to be very
complementary to the plaza to the
downtown area
and to future businesses
the new greyhound station is located
inside the regional transportation
commission
south strip transfer terminal and that's
just south of mccarran airport off
sunset road
and this is all being done in
conjunction with the plaza's celebration
of their 50th anniversary
and that's happening this summer
reporting from downtown las vegas bianca
holman 8 news now